with each new Pokemon game comes a new
set of Pokemon mechanics and a region to
discover and sword and shield or no
exception the vibrant gallery region is
a consistent delight to explore
incentivizing and rewarding different
types of players in equal measure and
grandiose battles add an exciting
dimension to the familiar gym formula
for an engaging adventure beginning to
end but most notably sword and shield
cut down on the tedious and protracted
elements bogging the series down in
favor of amplifying what makes it great
in the first place this is the most
balanced a Pokemon game has felt in a
long time and with that sword and shield
marked the best new generation of
Pokemon games in years
the game wastes no time in getting you a
starter Pokemon and off on your way to
becoming the champion you can reach the
new wild area an open expanse filled
with all kinds of Pokemon of all levels
within an hour or so of starting your
adventure and the wild area is the
show-stopping feature of this generation
pokemon roam the fields and lakes
changing the weather each day it's all
too easy to set out for one destination
only to be distracted by a Pokemon you
haven't caught yet an item glittering on
the ground in the distance or even an
evolved form of a pokemon that you
didn't realize you could catch in the
wild there's constantly something new to
do or discover and it's there to engage
you right out of the gate random
encounters are no more and instead you
see pokemon roaming Olive Gallery which
helps make each area feel lively and
distinct but there are some Pokemon that
remain hidden in the tall grass denoted
by an exclamation point you have to run
towards the wrestling grass to actually
initiate the fights you're never totally
caught by surprise some Pokemon can only
be found this way - this further
encourages you to fully explore each
locale while making return trips
painless free of constant interruptions
by wild Pokemon or stopping to use
repels for wild Pokemon battles are true
to the formula but for big battles sword
and shield strip out mega evolution and
Z moves in favour of a new battle
mechanic Dyna maxing which is sort of a
combination of the two and can only be
activated in certain locations a Dynomax
Pokemon grows to a massive size and is
stronger overall and its moves convert
to super-powered ones based on type it's
much more bombastic than mega evolution
or even Z moves but functionally it's
simpler and that's refreshing after
years of using both mega evolution and Z
moves and high-level battles Dyna maxing
is a welcome reset that also feels like
a natural evolution of the increasingly
high-octane battle mechanics of recent
games any pokémon can Dynomax - you're
just limited by location rather than an
item or a specific Pokemon so it's a
more flexible way to battle that works
for easygoing and competitive players
alike dynamaxx saying is a fixture of
the new max rates in which you and three
other people or NPCs take on a giant
Pokemon at certain locations in the wild
area raid Pokemon can vary from
run-of-the-mill easy to catch Pokemon to
ones that are incredibly hard to find in
the wild but regardless the
wards are fantastic completing a raid
even if the Pokemon escapes and you fail
to catch it Nets you tons of rare and
important items plus the Pokemon you get
from braids are guaranteed to have some
perfect stats so even duplicate Pokemon
are worth catching again it's a great
alternative to traditional competitive
play after you've beaten the game and
while it does feed into competitive
battling in both the item rewards and
the caliber of Pokemon you're catching
it's satisfying just to overcome the
challenge with friends new Pokemon are
fantastic - quite a few of them seem
geared for competitive play with moves
and abilities that inspire interesting
strategies but there are also the
aesthetically inclined Pokemon like the
incredibly gothcorp of night or the
adorable electric Corgi yam / to inspire
collectors throughout my journey I was
consistently delighted to discover each
new gen 8 pokémon and the gallery'
informs of older ones the Pokedex also
features a healthy mix of old pokemon
from each previous generation there are
certainly surprising omissions but like
with the new pokemon the list includes
both fun pokemon and competitive ones
plus an even spread of types sorting
shield might not have every pokemon in
existence but what's here is balanced
exquisitely for all types of players and
because there are items that give
Pokemon experience points now and
because you can access your Pokemon
boxes almost anywhere you can easily
change up your team on the fly without
having to stop and grind just to get a
new pokemon caught up in level I
experimented with different Pokemon more
during shields main story than I ever
did in a previous Pokemon game and it
made me appreciate the Genet Pokemon
even more small but significant quality
of life tweaks extend the competitive
side of the game to greatly reducing the
remaining barriers to entry there are
now items that allow you to change a
pokemons nature which was the final
missing piece and getting pokemon battle
ready without hours and hours of tedious
breeding and soft resetting in
collecting battling and exploring sword
and shield cut out the bloat and focus
on what makes these pillars of the
Pokemon games so captivating in the
first place there's definitely a lot of
challenge to be had but you're not held
back by overly complicated back-end
systems or hoops to jump through
from the outset you can start wandering
the gallery region seeing its new
pokemon and trying out its new battle
strategies with very little in your way
this leaves you free to enjoy what
pokemon is all about and that makes for
an incredibly strong showing for the
main series debut
on switch
[Music]
you